qu'est-ce que vous pensez de toute cette
séquence sur la position d'Amélie oua
cterin est-ce que vous appelez à cette
démission oui parce que elle n'est pas
compétente le sujet c'est pas la faute
politique à la commise d'avo c'est
évidemment c'est évidemment une insulte
pour l'ensemble de la communauté
éducative pour nos enfants pour la
jeunesse pour les enseignants pour les
autres membres de la communauté
éducative d'être traité stigmatisé de
cette manière c'est une faute mais c'est
surtout qu'elle connaît pas ce secteur
ruré dans l'émicycle cet après-midi ah
ben non on a l'impression qu'elle est là
pour faire du coaching d'entreprise elle
nous dit mais allons-y on va y arriver
soyons moderne soyons volontaires mais
enfin on parle de du premier budget de
l'État on parle d'une école qui est en
crise on parle d'enseignants qui sont
terrifiés aujourd'hui parfois face à
face à des enfants parce que les classes
sont surchargées parce que ils ont du
mal à vivre eux-mêmes les enseignants de
leurs revenus parce qu'ils savent que la
formation initiale comme la formation
continue sont défaillantes c'est c'est
là qu'on attend le gouvernement et là on
a des exercices c'est c'est un
gouvernement KTC on a des exercices de
communication en permanence et je pense
que tout ça doit absolument effrayer les
Français parce qu'ils se disent au fond
si la démocratie telle qu'elle est
exercée par le Président de la
République elle ne répond pas à mes
questions du cotidien le logement la
santé mon salaire le dérèglement
climatique et si c'est ce spectacle là
pourquoi défendre la démocratie vous
voyez le danger qu'est-ce que vous
retenez du coup de l'exercice d'hier de
ce grand oral cette conférence de presse
et c'est 8 million de téléspectateurs de
la part du chef de l'État quce vous avez
évoqué cet exercice c'est de la
communication politique écoutez je vais
vous dire la vérité j'ai regardé le
début hein quand j'ai vu qu'il
n'annonçait rien à part si vous voulez
là on a eu le même exercice du
gouvernement si franchement à chaque
fois que le Président de la République
où les membres du gouvernement mettent 1
€ dans une tirlire dès qu'ils utilisent
R mement réinvention remachin rruc je
vous assure que la dette de l'État
français va vite disparaître ce que je
veux dire c'est que à un moment donné
c'était tellement de l'autosatisfaction
heureusement qu'il y avait les
journalistes heureusement qu'il av la
presse pour poser les bonnes questions
céit une telle auto satisfaction je suis
passé sur allemagne- France de ball l'un
de ces réarmements c'est le réarmement
démographique face le réarmement ouiou
ououi c'est pour ça que je pose la
question c'est l'un des rements évoqués
hier à la conférence de presse alors
avec des annonces un congé de naissance
mieux rémunéré que le congé parental et
un plan contre l'infertilité mais vous
avez dénoncé les écologistes votre chef
de fil un discours paternaliste pourquoi
bah écoutez ce gouvernement il nous
parle du travail il nous parle euh de la
patrie euh et nous parle de la famille
enfin ça raisonne quand même dans notre
truc quand on parle de
l'école ah bah ça raisonne comme quelque
chose de profondément réactionnaire on
est passé du conservateur au réaction
ire c'estàdire qu'on a un discours d'un
président de la République plutôt que de
répondre à la fois de nous donner une
vision pour la France on est quand même
dans un contexte international
absolument dramatique le logement a
toujours pas de ministre alors que c'est
la première préoccupation c'est un
secteur en crise profonde l'école
l'hôpital le dérèglement climatique pas
un mot sur ces sujets de fond pas de
réponse sérieuse à ces sujets de fond un
exercice d'autosatisfaction alors il
réarme il réarme on a l'impression au
fond ils ont trouvé un un slogan pour
occuper les médias et finalement
désespérer tout le monde de la politique
c'est dramatique dans le contexte que
nous vivons il nous reste une minute
Yannick jado j'avais une dernière
question parisque vous êtes élu Parisien
ce matin Rachid adassti a dit moi je
suis élu parisienne mon objectif c'est
Paris moi j'ai une volonté c'est de
rassembler tous ceux qui veulent que ça
change à Paris je suis déterminé c'est
dans 3 ans bien sûr je toujours dit mais
elle sera donc bien candidate à
l'élection municipale en 2026 qu'est-ce
que vous évoque écoutez une insulte au
monde de la culture a besoin de soutien
et on sait l'importance de la culture y
compris dans ces situations de tension
des sociétés une insulte aux Parisiennes
aux Parisiens et alors c'est du pur
Rachid adati c'estàd que le Président de
la République dans les yeux des Français
le soir dit mais jamais on a discuté de
Paris avec Rachid hadti jamais oh mon
dieu jamais je rosis et Rachid hadti
sans filtre dès 8h 9h après la
déclaration du Président de la
République dit le monde de la culture je
m'en fous je ne suis ministre que pour
être candidate à Paris Fran elle pas dit
qu'elle s'en foutait du monde de la
culture mais elle elle elle on a quand
même depuis le début on a bien compris
qu'elle était ministre de la Culture
pour obtenir le soutien des macronistes
à l'élection parisienne et c'est comme
la ministre de l'Éducation c'est comme
d'autres ministres on a l'impression que
personne ne s'intéresse à sa propre
responsabilité encore une fois on joue
avec les ministères comme si entre les
vieux grognards qui sont restés euh les
derniers fidèles qu' ont accepté cette
dérive très à droite du macronisme et
puis les intrigants ou l'intrigante on a
l'impression qu'on s'est réparti au
hasard les ministères pour s'amuser et
ça c'est pas bien pour les Français
merci Yan pour cette déclaration en
direct au mcro de public
sén